[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a diario de copas el espacio
de france 24 donde analizamos la
actualidad de la copa américa y la
eurocopa a continuación nuestros
titulares
choque de candidatos en múnich en italia
y bélgica definen el pase a las
semifinales en el duelo de los dos
mejores equipos en lo que va del torneo
en los 'diablos rojos' la duda pasa por
la presencia de kevin de bruyne y eden
hazard
plato fuerte para los cuartos de final
de la copa américa brasil pone en juego
su corona ante chile que recupera a
alexis sánchez que apunta a su
generación dorada para dar el golpe
analizamos este encuentro
los cuartos de final de la copa américa
abren en goiánia perú envalentonado por
los últimos resultados se enfrenta a
paraguay que sufre por la baja de miguel
almirón repasamos que se puede esperar
de este encuentro
como en cada jornada nos acompañan sala
castro directora del diario hace
colombia bienvenidas ahora un gusto como
siempre federico vamos a empezar con la
eurocopa porque se acerca a su cierre
con el inicio de los cuartos de final y
en estos momentos hay acción
precisamente en san petersburgo se están
midiendo suiza y españa está ganando la
selección española 1 a 0 con el gol de
denis sacar ya en contra más tarde es el
gran duelo entre bélgica e italia en el
allianz arena de múnich en el historial
general la ventaja es abrumadora para la
azzurra pero la actualidad de ambos
equipos muestra paridad los dos ganaron
sus cuatro partidos en el torneo con la
salvedad de que italia se llevó su duelo
de octavos en la prórroga los diablos
rojos sólo han perdido un encuentro de
sus últimos ocho por eurocopa y natura
nunca perdió en grandes torneos contra
bélgica con tres victorias y un empate
es el primer duelo de eliminación
directa entre ambos escuchamos a los
entrenadores de ambos equipos
distin just kept este equipo de italia
ha mantenido todos los aspectos
resueltos y ganadores que siempre ha
tenido en grandes torneos y le ha sumado
flexibilidad para hacer un equipo
dinámico que defiende muy rápido e
indiferente
y capaz de jugar al uno contra uno en
todo el campo es una gran combinación en
esa combinación
sana
la baja de la posible baja de kevin de
bruyne y la de eden hazard son las que
despiertan la preocupación de roberto
martínez y pueden llegar a cambiar de
alguna manera en la forma en que plantea
el encuentro sin duda cualquier equipo
juega mejor con jugadores como de bruijn
o hazard eso está claro pero está
bélgica no depende de esas
individualidades esto porque porque
tiene mucho tiempo de trabajo roberto
martínez ya ha tenido que saldar digamos
este tipo de situaciones en otro en
otras oportunidades pero sobre todo
porque tiene a courtois en el arco una
defensa que aguantó los mejores momentos
de portugal en esta eurocopa
witsel en el mediocampo que es un
comandante y luego lukaku que ya hemos
hablado de todas las virtudes que tiene
como delantero recibiendo de espaldas
conduciendo y sobre todo generando
siempre mucha dificultad a la defensa
además es un equipo con juego directo es
decir que sabe aprovechar bien los
espacios y ha demostrado que es
pragmático entonces si bien es una baja
sensible creo que el equipo tiene las
condiciones y sobre todo las variantes
necesarias para saldarla
estas incógnitas con estas salvedades y
estas posibles ausencias en bélgica y de
italia puede ser considerada favorita de
cada este duelo y esto puede pesarle al
equipo de mancini italia favorita por lo
que mencionaba roberto martínez y es
esta convicción a una idea en la que en
todos los registros defensivo y ofensivo
hace las cosas muy bien es un equipo
profundo por sus laterales y extremos
pero también es un equipo que defiende
adelantado es un equipo que genera
muchos problemas en todas las zonas de
la cancha y ha sido esa convicción a la
idea de lo que nos ha hecho llamarlos el
mejor equipo del torneo el mejor equipo
en lo colectivo en que cada una de sus
fichas sabe muy bien qué hacer vamos a
ver y es si de pronto mancini cambien
algo desde su concepción defensiva cómo
cuidar no dejar esos espacios para que
los aprovechen jugadores como lukaku o
como carrasco si llega a entrar en ese
reemplazo de alguna manera en el sistema
de de bruyne es un equipo que nos ha
mostrado muy buen fútbol y sobre todo
eso no una idea que tiene que ver con su
adn de jerarquía ganadora de toda la
vida pero también con nuevas variantes
que sin duda le hace de tener un juego
más dinámico
perfecto en el otro gran torneo la copa
américa también inicia en los cuartos de
final este viernes con dos duelos de
gran interés así está el cuadro rumbo a
la final en el maracaná en el primer
turno de hoy van a jugar al perú
paraguay en el segundo brasil-chile para
el sábado queda en uruguay colombia y
argentina ante ecuador
sin dudas brasil-chile es uno de los
encuentros más atractivos en historial
favorece ampliamente a la verdeamarela
pero son los últimos campeones de la
copa en los que se enfrentan los de ti
te suman once partidos es sin perder
mientras que los de martín lasarte
fueron la última selección sudamericana
en vencer a brasil en un partido
competitivo en un juego de eliminatorias
en 2015 escuchamos lo que dijo tite
cuando fue consultado sobre si ya estaba
pensando en el próximo mundial
en este momento no estoy pensando en la
copa del mundo estoy pensando en este
juego en la copa américa en merecer la
victoria a través de nuestra actuación
técnica táctica física y emotiva
técnicas como si merecer más que el
adversario porque ellos también lo
merecen reconozco las habilidades de
nuestros oponentes juega el último
campeón de la copa américa contra el que
la ganó dos veces antes la grandeza de
este partido es mayor para ti te no
quiere que haya distracciones habla muy
bien sobre la selección chilena ha
tenido una primera fase en la que roto
mucho y es obviamente la gran favorita
pero que brasil podemos esperar que cara
de brasil podemos esperar esta noche
visto lo visto sigue siendo el mejor
torneo incluso con todas esas rotaciones
y habla de lo mismo de una idea que ha
sido trabajada a través del tiempo y que
a pesar de las fichas que ponga no
cambia el engranaje o ese estilo que
quiere proponer no le hemos visto entrar
digamos en esa tensión competitiva
digamos a profundidad a brasil y por eso
creemos que puede dar más y más en un
partido de este tipo van por su décimo
título en una copa américa
de la grandeza y sobre todo de un
proyecto que ya a través de ti te viene
siendo consolidado y va a ser un partido
interesante seguramente veremos a los
mejores jugadores jugando juntos como
vimos en algún momento animaría a
everton ribeiro que es cuando más
generar un juego ofensivo poniendo muy
en dificultad todo el bloque el
mediocampo de chile seguramente
intentarán poner en problemas a pulgar
para que no piense y no pueda sacar el
equipo así que es un partidazo por el
lado de chile recupera alexis sánchez se
tiene a toda su vieja guardia a
disposición y ha tenido tiempo para
preparar el partido que no queda muchos
otros equipos les les ha faltado le va a
alcanzar como para dar el golpe o dar
pelea hoy dice las dos claves y es la
'vieja guardia' y es estos partidos se
ganan con jugadores de experiencia con
jugadores que estén acostumbrados a
estar este tipo de presión y lo otro son
esas unidades de trabajo extra que se
han logrado a través de este descanso la
recuperación de jugadores clave y por
supuesto que además en el planteamiento
de brasil también entre jugar si alexis
sánchez va a estar o no porque sin duda
en ese sistema con vargas y con bretón
que seguramente serán los delanteros
a generar digamos alguna dificultad
adicional a la saga de brasil hoy estaba
revisando el gol que colombia le hace y
es posible jugarle brasil es posible
tocar la pelota y es posible circular la
generando digamos esa incomodidad
también para un equipo que tiene grandes
jugadores como los brasil el otro gran
partido que vamos a tener hoy el que va
a abrir este viernes de copa américa
promete mucha paridad entre perú y
paraguay se han enfrentado 54 veces con
24 triunfos de paraguay 16 de perú en 17
choques por copa américa la albirroja
ganó 7 y la blanquirroja sólo 3 pero es
el historial reciente el que entusiasma
perú los de ricardo gareca han ganado
seis de los últimos siete encuentros el
último fue el empate por las
eliminatorias y paraguay no gana desde
un amistoso en 2014 esto dijo sergio
peña mediocampista de perú sobre él
durante paraguay el y el presente de su
equipo
creo que estamos muy bien
estamos demostrado demostrando partido a
partido de qué
ya que somos una selección muy dura
grandes candidatos así que
que sin duda alguna lo que vamos a hacer
es luchar hasta el final para lograr el
objetivo que es es obtener la copa
paraguay es es un rival
bastante duro pero nosotros siempre
mantenemos nuestra esencia mantenemos
nuestro nuestra idea nuestra idea la
tenemos muy clara así que vamos a
mantener eso para poder sacar el partido
a favor pero llegaba con dudas en este
torneo pero los buenos resultados le han
dado un envión y han demostrado que es
un equipo que se adapta bien a las copas
américas en este caso le puede alcanzar
este envión para llegar a semifinales es
un partido muy interesante desde lo
táctico porque a berisso le hemos visto
muy buenas propuestas durante el torneo
y gareca que tiene muy buen conocimiento
de su estilo y de su sistema ha
demostrado eso que los torneos cortos
pueden lograr rendimientos muy
interesantes hay que ver cómo funciona
en cueva y carrillo que son los que le
dan esa salida a perú
y seguro van a poner en problemas a un
paraguay que da más cuenta con una baja
fundamental que es la de almirón porque
ellos saben hacer un muy buen sistema
defensivo organizarse muy bien en el
campo pero almirón es ese jugador que no
sólo saca sino que pone en problemas a
la defensa rival es un partido
interesante yo creo que ya en este punto
vamos a empezar a ver la verdadera cara
de muchos equipos que llegaron con dudas
y con incertidumbres
la copa américa en el caso de paraguay
esta baja del millón cuanto puede pesar
muchísimo almirón ha sido el mejor
jugador en todos los partidos de la
selección de paraguay porque es un
jugador que tiene uno contra uno es un
jugador talentoso y que una vez sale con
el balón impulsa también al equipo
adelantar un poco las líneas a generar
más tensión en el equipo rival muy bien
en esta edición de diario de copas
también repasamos otras noticias en este
caso todas vinculadas a la eurocopa
el mediocampista a toni kroos anunció su
retiro de la selección de alemania tras
la eliminación en los octavos de final
ante inglaterra el jugador aseguró que
tenía la decisión tomada de dejar la
mancha fue tras este torneo y dijo que
se concentrará en red en realmadrid y en
pasar su tiempo con la familia una
selección jugó 106 partidos marcó 17
goles y fue campeón del mundo en 2014
república checa- piensa en el duelo de
cuartos de final ante dinamarca en bakú
algunos jugadores del equipo han
manifestado su malestar por jugar en
azerbaiyán debido al largo traslado que
implica en lo deportivo se espera el
regreso de vladimir de ida al mediocampo
tras superar una lesión muscular
dinamarca también práctico en bakú en la
previa al encuentro con república checa
el capitán de simon kjaer es uno de los
jugadores que arrastran molestias
físicas pero el seleccionador kasper
hillmán que espera contar con lo mejor
que tiene a disposición para ese duelo
[Música]
bueno muchísimas gracias por
acompañarnos nuevamente y una línea
simplemente sobre este retiro de toni
kroos y lo que significó para alemania
si justamente estado pensando esto no
como estos torneos más allá de entregar
un título también generan cierres de
ciclos como este de toni kroos en algún
punto el jugador se da cuenta que ya lo
está a ese nivel que quisiera estar para
representar a su selección y se enfoca
en otras cosas sin duda pues va a ser
mucha falta en el fútbol además un
jugador que desde que fue el mejor en el
torneo sub-20 no ha dejado de conseguir
cosas para su selección una baja
sensible también para alemania y un
proceso nuevo que inicia a ustedes
muchísimas gracias por acompañarnos y
sigan con más en france 24 y france24
puntocom
[Música]